[Music]
okay great thanks everyone for coming
really suck to be here today speaking to
you at cloud next my name is Chris
Broadfoot I'm an engineer on the
developer relations team and today I'm
going to be talking to you about
minimizing apt latency at scale and I'll
go into a little bit bit about what I
think that means I spoke to some people
outside as we were waiting to come in
what it means to them and what they are
trying to get out of this talk and
there's little bits for everyone I hope
but will generally be speaking at a
pretty high level I'm going to give you
some ideas and draw on some of my
personal experiences working on
production apps at Google even though
I'm in developer relations I've had some
you know side projects essentially
twenty percent and I'll show you some
real graphs and screenshots to so notes
and slides will eventually be at this
URL I'll be referencing some some things
and you'll be able to find links under
that link so yeah performance and
latency is a really difficult subject to
talk about at this conference you might
have noticed that it's one of the this
talk is one of the few that you know
sort of talking about things at a high
level it's not we're not talking about
specific products or anything like that
so you're probably a really diverse
audience of mobile web back-end
developers there's probably some of you
in IT and ops as well so i'll be trying
to keep things sort of general and give
a bit of give a bit of information for
everyone i'm going to take a holistic
approach which I think it's generally
the right way to approach performance
and latency and things like that so why
are you here why do we care about it
you've probably already acknowledged
that you care about latency because
you're here or watching this talk on
YouTube this is a pretty famous quote
and it's kind of become a rule of thumb
I think so Greg Linton who at the time
was at amazon this was about 10 years
ago I think now found that 10 100
millisecond increasing page latency
caused about a 1 percent drop in revenue
and we're ten years on now but i think
these results are still still kind of
correct and they've been replicated
across multiple companies including
Google and Bing
I'm gonna have some links to some
references for this but yet does this
really apply to you that is that's the
question does this apply to your app
obviously if your apps doesn't have
revenue then it doesn't at all right
okay let's first find latency it's
essentially the delay between request
and response but what's application
latency you came here so this talk the
title is minimizing app latency okay
it's I think it's just a made-up term
there are about 30,000 results on Google
so I'm going to define it here today so
application latency I'm proposing if the
delay between a user's action and update
so this is essentially a holistic UX
thing so the latency is the time user
presses a button or initiate an action
and when they see a result there's
actually nothing to do with networking
or anything like that although it is
related when does it matter a good rule
of thumb is that your most common cases
should be faster so given a blog service
viewing a blog post is the most frequent
action maybe a lot of people a lot of
blogs are unwritten not read very often
going down to viewing the comments for a
blog so maybe as you scroll down load
those in later commenting on a blog post
and publishing and editing so
essentially the right operations and
then finally the most infrequent
operation is creating a new blog
although perhaps more blogs are created
than poster created so that might be the
wrong thing to optimize for there's an
interesting anecdote which I think was
from blogger the blog creation process
that is creating an entire new site was
so fast that users thought that
something was wrong they would click
create new blog and boom it would just
happen and I think that left users
wondering whether something really
happened at all or not so sometimes fast
it's not better optimized so user
satisfaction over everything else so we
might be able to change from frequent
too infrequent too insignificant to
significant right maybe significant
operations are slower because it
it's a the user is committing something
so maybe they expect you to commit
something back right so they expect
something to be slower so the next thing
I want to talk about its managing user
expectations right when can you get away
with making things slow if you can't
make things fast then make the user
understand why things are slow right I
think we can all understand that re
architecting our applications in a way
to make things faster sometimes not
possible so when can we get away with
slow things we already talked about more
infrequent operations just telling the
user it's going to take a while might be
good enough and more importantly telling
them why it's going to take a while
giving users frequent updates and
indications it's also really good tell
them why it's happening and what's
happening under the hood so an app does
this really well it's just a big query
user interface there could be some
improvements obviously but what it does
when you get run query it just has a
timer a stopwatch that goes up and so
this is giving users some indication
that something is happening they don't
really know exactly what's happening
under the hood although once the job is
completed you can see the explanation
for the query and it tells you
importantly how many keywords with
process so it's telling you why this
operation took so long right because we
processed all of these gigabytes of data
so this sets user expectations they know
they're querying huge data sets but
they're only happening in 17 seconds
whereas this operation obviously you
know something taking 17 seconds might
not be appropriate for other
applications I'm thinking about like
game servers or something like that
where we're talking like you know tens
of milliseconds rather than you know
tens of seconds right so you have to
consider everything in context so
breaking down at a really high level
application latency we can think of
things so on the left of this slide
would be the user initiating in action
and on the right when they see the
actual update we have the any network
request which I think a lot of people
here are concerned about which consists
of latency of the requests going out
whatever is happening on the server and
maybe you
dependent servers from there and then
the time it takes to come back there may
be some sort of on device processing
like storing the results in a local
cache or database and then whatever
happens in the UI so like reflows and
repaints these are all part of
application latency so this is what the
user experiences so one trick that you
might know is to sort of decouple these
things to reduce the perceived latency
so maybe doing some of this work up
front just and sending off the network
requests in the background a really good
example of this is anything with a like
a like button or a +1 button or
something like that right the UI updates
instantaneously the app confirms that
the user made it performs an action and
the network network requests happens in
the background so you might do some sort
of on device processing beforehand like
storing the fact that the user initiated
this action so that you could possibly
retry the action in future or or or
display that the network request failed
or something like that and now actually
using this this graphic we're going to
look at each of these boxes separately
throughout the talk so we're actually
going to start more from the UI side
we've been talking a lot about UX stuff
but yes we will be talking about
networking and things like that ok so
how do you know what the slow part of
your app is we need to figure out what's
slow and how to fix it and what the
problems are Google Analytics does this
automatically for web applications this
is actually a real app that I have
worked on I've anonymize the page URL
but it gives you a really nice
indication of several important
statistics in this case the document
interactive time which is when the page
can be interacted with so this is
separate from Dom content loaded if
you're a web developer which i think is
a poor metric this is a better metric so
this is a really simple way to figure
out which of your pages are slow
so once you figured out which pages are
slow using the chrome developer console
or the equivalent for Android or iOS
it's a really good way to figure out
exactly what's happening so this is
actually a time line graph of gmail
which is incredibly complicated
application so it shows you things like
what javascript is running what network
regrets are happening and what paints
and things like that that are happening
compiler like compositors on the GPU
things like that so you can figure out
exactly what's happening inside your
application detecting the document
interactive time and Dom content loaded
are good but even better is getting
actual timings from your real from your
from your users so you might have some
sort of lazy loading or something like
that with google analytics you can send
these timings to to Google Analytics and
you'll be able to slice and dice it like
any other any other events or triggers
or anything that happens inside
analytics so it's a really handy way to
to customize your timings once you've
figured out exactly what what components
of your page or application that you
want to figure out so this is the same
code for java so on android and you'll
end up in the analytics with with a
graph like this so this is this is a
real app again so you get climbing
buckets the most interesting thing I
think for me are the ones but take the
florist I want to figure out how many of
my users are going to become disengaged
so anything above I think a good rule of
thumb again is about three seconds after
three seconds of users going to become
disengaged and we can figure out
globally where these uses are so I'm
from Australia things are really slow in
Australia generally and it's no
different for this particular
application although i think these
statistics are faulty 840 seconds it's a
long time I don't think things are I
don't think things are that quite bad
but um yeah so
so yet going back let's talk about
network requests now why I think slow
slow slow from Australia okay so a good
first step if you haven't already is
setting up monitoring for your back end
or your front end both are good this is
just the the way to add an uptime check
in stackdriver monitoring and after you
do that it'll send a request every
minute or however you however often you
want and give you a graph like this so
it's important to note that these are
actual timings from stackdriver not an
average of all of your user requests or
anything like that this is really good
for detecting if your app is up and
getting a sense of how long things are
taking on your back end but it's only
measuring things from the perspective of
the stack driver Probus right these are
not actual timings from your users so
it's really not that useful it's good
for keeping track of uptime but not for
identifying issues so how do we identify
issues using tracing and those user
metrics are really important too so now
we're sort of diving into this remote
processing like whatever is happening on
your server why are things happening so
slow why the request taking so long so
stick driver trace is the way to do this
this is enabled by default so App Engine
standard and this app is actually an app
engine standard app and you get this
nice dot plot graph showing requests
over time and whichever ones were
sampled and sort of where they are so on
the y-axis is the latency and you can
see some of the requests are getting up
there over that sort of three second
mark where we where we're getting
concerned and generally the slow ones
are the most interesting ones to see to
look at and you can actually click on
these specific dots to look at the
traces of those specific requests and
there's also this sweet auto reload
thing and you can see the traces come
through live another really interesting
view in stackdriver trace is this
latency profile so the the graph Ian
orange is this week and the blue is the
preview
week it's actually really interesting
that SAP has such a consistent latency
profile I'd expect these things to
change you know a fair bit weak weak
yeah this is a really great way to see
how many of your users are in sort of
each bucket that you care about so you
know there are some users above that
three-second mark and you'll be able to
see that sort of like the percentage of
people that are becoming disengaged it's
also the comparison is also interesting
to detect regressions in your
application performance so sector iver
also produces reports it'll provide
sample traces for each sort of
percentile buckets and so again I think
the most the most important ones to look
at of the slowest ones so this is a
single trace it's one of the slower ones
inside this particular app running on
App Engine standard you can see it's
doing a bunch of memcache data store
requests and then sort of nothing
happens after the one second mark right
we have no idea what the application is
doing so what happened there I don't
know I haven't instrumented this
particular app but using a stack driver
API to provide custom spans so each of
these particular timings is called a
span it's the way to do that there's
also Zipkin integration so if you're
already using Zipkin sort races well if
you're using trite whoo-hoo huger is
tracing already okay that's that's a
pretty good amount so if you're using a
tracing products already there might be
an integration with stackdriver with
Zipkin you can send those you can send
all those traces to look at them in this
great UI yeah so how do we mitigate
these flow requests so for example here
maybe there's some sort of processing
event or something like that happening
we don't know so how do you mitigate
them I think a really good way to and if
you can afford to is to write these
requests to lately low latency event to
use and other services so I'm not going
to teach you how to create an event
pipeline or or
or anything like that but what I'm
essentially suggesting here is to store
these payloads somewhere else
temporarily before you can process and
ingest them so make those client
requests asynchronous I've talked to a
bunch of people outside who are using
App Engine task queues are a really good
way of doing this very high performance
you can put you can put those requests
in there and process them with a push or
pork you as you have capacity to do so
the the rate that you do that might rely
on whatever underlying services you're
using so if using data store for example
you might only want to write you know
100 requests per second or something
like that cloud storage spanner and pops
up are also really good spanner and GCF
cloud storage have multi region modes
which means that if your servers are
globally distributed you'll be all right
into those quickly and and rest support
for task users coming soon so you'll be
able to use those outside of App Engine
so maybe we identified a function or a
handler that's performing poorly I think
the next thing to do is to profile those
profile that function so p prof is a
open source tool from google for
visualizing and analyzing that profiling
data you get the profiling data through
other tools like Linux's perf tool and
this is generally good for things that
are CPU bound or i/o bound or something
like that you can figure out exactly
what's happening so on the left is the
output from the paper off command line
tool basically see the the top functions
you can dig in deeper through different
methods and on the right it's a very
complicated graphical output which shows
you basically like call graphs and how
long things are taking I think the
larger boxes are things that take longer
we're more CPU time is spent and another
really great way to visualize this is
using a plane graph so the colors
actually don't mean anything I think
that's where the name flame comes from
the
basically the the width oh and the
x-axis isn't anything to do with time or
anything like that the wider the block
the more often it shows up in in stack
inspect races for the profile and at the
very top other things actually spending
CPU time this is a good way to identify
potential things to fix so in this one I
don't know like optimizing text template
or something like that maybe adding a
casing layer there is appropriate so
after you've figured out a particular
function or method that needs to be that
needs to be improved benchmarking is a
really good way of doing this I always
say to profile first otherwise you're
kind of benchmarking in the dark you
really want to figure out what to
benchmark first and find problem areas
it's also really important to replicate
these results in production so
production environments very like differ
greatly from your workstation in terms
of the performance characteristics so
there's things like hypervisors feels an
interesting story I think a couple days
ago about the get time of day school
taking a really long time on it wasn't
what would you see but another cloud
provider so you might have problems like
that that only manifest themselves in
productions so you really need to run
these profiling and benchmarking on your
production environment generally these
fans have a lot of raw processing power
obviously it depends how big your VMs
and they might be different
characteristics for writing to desk or
anything like that right like if you
have SSDs or or network attached to you
score something like that your
application might perform quite
differently another way your application
perform performance might change is
under load so it's really really
important to do load testing I worked on
an application a few years ago that
completely fell apart under load right
it ran really quickly when a small
amount of load was sent at it but once
once it was replicated and adding
production you know many many different
call
Runes of the service I just didn't scale
once actual load was sent at it so this
is a good thing to do okay let's talk
about getting close to your users we're
going to talk about network latency now
basically so the request and response
latency okay so sec drive back to sac
driver monitoring this is another
interesting plot the one I showed you
previously aggregated all of the latency
profiles from all the spec drivers
locations but this one splits them out
separately so you can see here the the
orange line which generally at the top
or the pink one which sau Paulo and
Singapore respectively of the slowest
ones presumably that's because this
application is posted in the US or
something like that this is a really
good a good way to get an idea of how
your application performs across the
globe from your different users so you
might not actually care about this I was
talking to someone who has an
application only for us users this is
not going to be useful for them right
but if your Google Analytics tells you
that you have users across the world you
know the poor sods in Singapore or
Australia or whatever the app is really
slow for them and maybe you have no idea
but this is giving you an indication and
if we zoom out this graph this is this
is another production app by the way oh
and say which but if you zoom out you
also see these huge spikes across a week
right what I have no idea what happened
there but this is another great way to
figure out when to dig in a little more
it's interesting that this application
spiked only in certain regions right
what why singapore so slow for over a
day there's also a lot of there's also a
lot of variants from the other regions
there too so maybe maybe there was an
outage or something like that okay so
now you figured out where your app is
slow the thing to do is to figure out
where your users are put things close to
them whether it be front end servers
so you can serve out your your content
to them or back ends so maybe like
replicating distributing data that's
important for them so so for example if
you have users in Asia maybe you want
you you probably want to store their
data closest to them so that they can
access it really quickly maybe you also
replicate it across to other regions but
it should be available close to them so
this might be something like a read-only
replica and you'll have a trade-off here
between lowering latency and data
consistency across the world right a
right that happens in Asia it's it's
only possible to make it to the US 200
milliseconds later right so the user in
the u.s. is trying to read from it
they'll see something different you
can't you can't be physics right so
there's trade-offs to do there one
really easy way that will be available
soon to mitigate this is using spanner
which will have a multi-region database
so that was actually demoed this morning
the multi region database so that'll
hopefully make things quickly quick to
access from any region okay so once you
have all these servers across the world
you need to use load balancing and the
cloud load balancer gives you
intelligent routing based on the
location of the user and so the closest
instances don't have enough capacity
then it will send the request to the
nearest region after that so you'll
always be hitting the closest servers to
your user it also gives you things like
automatic logging including latency
statistics so from the perspective of
the load balancer how long did think
stake so this is really good and it's a
it's a pretty it's a pretty easy thing
to enable and it also integrates really
well into cloud CDN which is not really
like a traditional CDN where they get
where you give them all of your assets
and they distribute them across the
world but it uses Google's globally
distributed edge points and points of
presence I'm sorry and they cash HTTP
traffic and requests closest to your
user
so caching things that the edge of
Google's network provides faster
delivery of content while reducing seven
costs so these these requests aren't
being sent across across networks it's
closest to you users fast and cheap so
these are these are the points of
presence I think the the blue dots the
dark blue dots and the blue lines
represent Google's network and there are
many pairing partners as well so it's it
was mentioned in the keynote this
morning actually so the pairing partners
means that it's likely there's only one
hop between your users and the content
that you need to serve to them and this
also means that as much traffic as
possible is sent through Google's
network so even if that request does
need to go from Asia to America it's
happening over Google's network wherever
if you've heard all about the the
excellence and performance of the
network this morning but yeah this is
this is a really great way to go so it's
really easy to enable on your load
balancer config you just hit a check box
I don't know why you wouldn't do it
maybe if you're concerned about content
being stored in different places but
just hit enable or run this g-cloud
command and it will just work and by
just work I mean you need to do a little
bit of work not all HTTP responsible
responses are cacheable it'll only cash
ones that meet these criteria so in
short this there's a bunch more inside
the documentation but basically it needs
to be get requests you need to set cache
headers it needs to be a like an okay
status code essentially and you need to
set a content length and it also can't
be a large request or anything with a
set cookie header so this is good for
static assets that it's going to be
common across multiple users doesn't
have any personalized information or
anything like that
another really cool thing you can do is
set your own maps inside the load
balancer you can basically say send
requests to my back ends and send static
requests to my Google Cloud Storage
bucket and obviously all of that gets
monitored and logged and and it's
fronted by a cloud CDN so what you need
to do there if you're backing URL paths
with cloud storage is to set the case
settings on your Cloud Storage bucket
basically you want to say you know
Keysha Keysha all these efforts are not
going to change very often maybe you
don't care if they if they get cached
forever you can be clever about changing
your L paths or something like that if
you need to flush the cases there's also
ways to flush the cases that the edge
knows that's in the documentation as
well this should reduce the the latency
particularly for users that aren't
anywhere near the zones of your backends
ok so so starting to wrap up we've
looked at various aspects of application
latency or sort of perceived performance
comprising the the performance of these
network requests whatever is happening
on the device including UI updates
whether you can do any tricks to send
things asynchronously both on the
front-end and the backend and getting
close to users to reduce that network
latency ok
but importantly make it fast enough
remember that story about creating blogs
don't make it too fast because your
users might get freaked out take a
completely holistic approach you might
have a front-end and back-end teams make
sure they're working together to reduce
the apparent latency for your users
measure their actual latency from your
users devices and test from real devices
you can use things like Charles proxy to
introduce packet loss and latency and
load bandwidth there's also ways on the
Android and iOS simulators to to do this
yeah collect timings and metrics from
your actual users and instrument your
backends we're tracing so you can figure
out exactly what's going on consider
your user's location device and
networking capability so again you know
simulating packet loss is a really good
thing figure out how your app performs
in poor conditions and use global load
balancing and CDMS it so really it's a
really low risk way of making things
faster but above all else focus on user
satisfaction if you use as a happy then
you probably don't have to do anything
right making things faster you have to
think about what impact that's going to
have on your users maybe you can better
spend that time that you would have
spent on performance working on a
feature or something like that if you
have the luxury to have multiple
performance engineers or something like
that then this is great just keep
investigating figure out where things
are coming from and mitigate them and
that's it
[Music]
you